so perhaps you heard about the big
political scandal that uh broke
yesterday this was major news big big
deal the media was going crazy over it
was all
that anybody was talking about on
twitter uh there were calls for
resignations and investigations was it
was a big big deal
right massively important story
at least that's what i have been assured
repeatedly and loudly over the course of
the past 24 hours the scandal get ready
for this if you haven't heard yet
the scandal is that uh ted cruz
went on vacation with his family that's
i'll pause right here and let you
collect yourself for a moment because i
know it takes
a minute to recover from hearing
something as shocking as this
yes ted cruz went on vacation i'll say
it again so that the severity of this
situation
can sink in uh i repeat ted cruz
went on vacation why does this matter
why is it important why should it garner
all the headlines and
and so much controversy well you know
you'll have to ask somebody else
frankly because i don't see it but it
but it does matter
that's what i'm told it matters a lot
you should care you must care
now let's let's back up um and let's
let's try to figure out why we should
care so much about this we'll
back up for a minute as the story goes
ted cruz was spotted at the airport
thursday morning with his family
boarding a plane for
cancun this is scandalous supposedly
because
uh texas is in the midst of a crisis
with millions of
of its citizens without power and
stranded because of the winter storms
as the scandal broke and texas democrats
called for his resignation about it
and every media outlet turned the whole
thing into uh pearl harbor
cruz announced that uh he would be
returning immediately from cancun and
that he was only
going there to escort his family
implying that he'd always
plan to to bring them and then turn
around and fly back and come back home
he later admitted though that he
actually cut his trip short that he was
planning to go for the week or however
long
and he decided to turn around and come
back that night the new york times had
an exclusive report
featuring private text messages between
cruz's wife
heidi and that and her friends and they
publish these private text messages
here's the
here's the the times here's what they
reported like millions of his
constituents across texas senator ted
cruz had a frigid home without
electricity this week amid the state's
power crisis
but unlike most mr cruz got out fleeing
houston and hopping
a wednesday afternoon flight to cancun
with his family for a respite at a
luxury resort
photos of mr cruz and his wife heidi
boarding the flight ricocheted quickly
across social media left both his
political allies and rivals
gassed a guest at a tropical trip
as a disaster unfolded at home the
blowback only and testified intensified
after
mr cruz a republican released a
statement saying that he had flown to
mexico
to be a good dad and accompany his uh
daughters and their friends
he noted he was flying back thursday
afternoon though he did not disclose how
long he had originally intended to stay
text messages sent from miss cruz to
friends and houston neighbors on
wednesday revealed a hastily planned
trip their house was quote freezing as
ms cruz put it and she proposed a
getaway until sunday
ms cruz invited others to join them at
the ritz carlton in cancun
where they had stayed quote many times
noting the room price this week 300
a night and it's good security um
the text messages were provided to the
new york times and confirmed by a second
person on the thread who declined to be
identified
because of the private nature of the
texts okay
so that gets us up to speed on the
controversy
now a few things here number one
this is not a scandal okay
there there's no actual reason why ted
cruz
should stay in texas he's not going to
be pulling out his toolbox and
going to fix the power grid himself is
it a good look
to leave is it good optics no obviously
not
it was a political blunder a political
mistake
but that's another way of saying that
that there's nothing
actually wrong with taking his family to
a warm place it only
looks wrong it's not actually wrong it
just
looks bad so if you want to slam him
for for doing something that looks bad
uh if you want to hit him for being
politically careless
then fine but if you pretend that
there's some deeper scandal here some
actually corrupt behavior involved in
this guy taking a
vacation at cancun then you're being
absurd you're being ridiculous
in fact to hit him on the optics is to
admit that's the point about
optics if we say that something is bad
optics
from a politician what we're saying is
it's not actually
bad it just looks bad but we know it's
not actually bad well if you know that
it's not actually bad then stop
pretending like stop
acting as though you think it is um
you know that said he obviously was not
planning to fly with his family down to
cancun and then turn around and come
back
as he seemed to imply initially so he
shouldn't have implied that
so he's handled this badly there's no
question about it still it's not a major
scandal
or a scandal at all it's a gaff okay
there's a difference between
a gaff and a scandal a gaffe is when a
politician does something that looks
really stupid and bad
but there's no corruption no crime
no real unethical behavior taking place
so it's a gaff number two given that
this is not a real scandal
publishing private text messages with
cruz's wife and her friends
is scummy behavior almost as scummy as
whatever quote-unquote friend
uh sent the text to the media in the
first place
imagine what a scumbag you have to be to
do that you've got your neighbor
inviting you on a trip uh and
and what do you do you immediately
contact the new york times
to throw her husband under the bus now
there may be a scenario where it would
be ethical for the media to publish
text messages between a politician's
wife and her friends
there may be a situation where that
would be ethical if there is
this is not that situation a trip to
cancun
is not that situation maybe if there was
criminal behavior taking place and you
had text messages that proved it then
then okay
that might be a reason to publish them
this is not criminal behavior or
anything close to it so there's no
excuse to publish text messages
number three people on social media
especially on the left have been drawing
comparisons between this
and the democrats like newsom who went
to restaurants or hairdressers during
the lockdowns
um and many were claiming that this
thing with crews
is is in fact worse somehow than
the stuff with uh nancy pelosi at the
hairdresser or newsome at the
at the restaurant or uh the mayor of
chicago going to the hairdresser saying
that
that at least it's on par if not worse
the cruz thing that's that's the claim
which is utterly ridiculous the outrage
over newsom
and others it wasn't that they were off
having a good time during the pandemic
that's not the problem
okay nobody cares if they have a good
time i don't care if they have a good
time or not that makes no difference to
me
the scandal was that they were doing
what they had forbidden the citizens of
their state
from doing they were breaking their own
rules
and laws and policies they were passing
rules
saying you guys cannot do this and if
you do it we'll find you we'll arrest
you
and then they turned around and did that
thing that's the scandal
and that's a real scandal that's real
corruption that's abuse of power
so that's the difference so there you
have a scandal
as opposed to a gaff from cruz
uh from cruz at best bad optics not an
abuse of power it's not cruz violating
laws that he helped to pass or any other
law
he's not violating any law rule at all
in fact to equate these two things is
obviously misleading in the extreme
number four most importantly however you
feel about
cancun gate you should understand why
the media was focusing
so intently on this you can argue that
it was
a bad thing for cruz to do a stupid
thing
but you cannot reasonably or credibly
argue
that it deserves all the headlines and
the attention that it got so why did it
get that attention well i
submit that probably had something to do
with this
the times union the paper in albany uh
several hours before the big cruz
news broke had this report quote
uh the fbi and the us attorney's office
in brooklyn have launched an
investigation that
is examining at least in part the
actions of governor andrew cuomo's
coronavirus task force in its handling
of nursing homes and other long-term
care facilities during the pandemic
the probe by the us attorney's office in
the eastern district of new york
is apparently in its early stages and is
focusing on the work of some of the
senior members of the governor's task
force according to a person with direct
knowledge of the matter who is not
authorized
to speak publicly um okay so
there is a an fbi investigation there's
a lot more to this report by the way you
can go to the times union and read about
it
there's an fbi investigation into andrew
cuomo um the governor of new york
who was hailed as the covet hero now
he's being investigated by the fbi
for a scandal an actual scandal that led
to the deaths of thousands of people
right as news of this investigation was
beginning to spread suddenly the major
story
is ted cruz going to cancun
i don't think this is a coincidence now
you could argue that
even without the story from from cuomo
the media would still be making hay with
the cruise
quote unquote scandal because it's a
republican and it's their opportunity
to embarrass a republican and that's
probably true too i think all of these
things are related
what we do know though is that the
crew's story does not deserve the
attention that it got
and yet you go on social media and you
find even conservatives
who are joining in the outrage bandwagon
willfully being manipulated by the media
the media wants you to see this as a
much bigger deal than it is
they want you to see they are telling
you to see it as on par
with newsome they want you to focus on
this instead of the cuomo thing
and even now so many conservatives are
happy to go along
even now are happy to say well okay if
you tell me this is what i should care
about
it's absolutely absurd and by the way
just to just to
reiterate reinforce what i said at the
very top here
um you know
ted cruz is not going to be going and
fixing
the power grid now maybe what you want
him to do
is to do the photo ops and to go out and
to hand out hand out cups of soup or
whatever
um and that's what a lot of politicians
in fact do in these circumstances
why do they do that you know if there's
some sort of natural disaster
and the politicians are there themselves
personally
you know handing out the soups and
waving to the cameras why are they doing
that
is it because they care about is it
because they care about their citizens
no it's because it's a political
opportunity they don't act nobody needs
them in fact it's it's better for them
not to be there because when they're
there then there's
there's there's media there's security
it's actually
better logistically to not have them
they can delegate that
i'm not saying that a senator should be
doing nothing in response to
a crisis like this in his state but he
can delegate it
he can get on the phone privately make
phone calls send people out to do things
he doesn't need to personally be there
himself and in fact it's probably
better all things concerned if he's not
the reason why the politicians
themselves personally want to be there
is for the photo up i don't understand
why
so that i understand why they the
politician wants to do that
why do citizens want that from their
politicians
why do you want a politician to do the
photo op
i don't need that personally
it's not something that i need to see
and i'd prefer if not
if we didn't see it
now if there's evidence that ted cruz
even behind the scenes is doing nothing
whatsoever hasn't delegated anything
hasn't made any phone calls
hasn't sent any of his people out to uh
you know to go hand out the soup and to
go to the warming stations
you know if there's evidence that he's
done absolutely nothing behind the
scenes then fine you can get him on that
but i don't see any reason to assume
that all we know is that he was not
originally going to be going himself for
the photo op now he is going to go for
the photo op
and i guess a lot of people feel more
comfortable and they feel comfortable
now oh thank god we've got the
politician doing the photo up i don't
get it
being manipulated by the media let's all
uh let's all try to be better than that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated